[Music]
on this Saturday night Western Canada's
Deep Freeze from dangerous roads to
canceled flights how the record-breaking
cold is wreaking havoc and putting
people and pets at risk yeah we're close
to the as cold as it gets and the
massive power problems blamed on the
polar vortex meet taiwan's new
[Music]
president how does historic win enraged
Beijing it was the number one issue
racist or personal replica a Montreal
puppeteers blackface
controversy plus swimming closer to
Extinction what was well-intentioned had
this unintended consequence why laws to
protect sharks may have
backfired global national with bar
Asser good evening to you and I hope
you're joining us bundled up from from
inside Canada is known to be cold but
the biting winds and bitter temperatures
blanketing the West have shattered
temperature records in some areas and
now that system is heading east weather
warnings and watches cover the entire
country tonight in fact from coast to
coast to coast across Eastern Canada
warnings and watches and travel
advisories as some powerful storms move
through and then in the west there's
that sea of red where bone chilling
temperatures are sweeping across the
Prairies and parts of Beast
making it feel anywhere from -40 to -50
with the
windchill the Arctic air hanging over
Western Canada's been impacting
everything from travel to power even our
food supply Katherine urkhart has the
latest on the extreme cold
snap in downtown Vancouver the Deep
Freeze resulted in down trolley wires
and icy conditions caused Chaos on
countless streets the last few days
since the temperatures dropped roadside
assistance requests have doubled in
Prince George it plunged to minus
39° a record low it was a similar story
around the province some admitted they
were unprepared it came as a shock after
the bommy fall we were having Outreach
teams monitored the marginalized
population in Colona offering them warm
drinks and rolling out buses as
temporary shelters a lot of our unhoused
community members they've been able to
access these warming buses which has
been
incredible across Alberta temperatures
hit minus 40 and lower the Sika First
Nation issued a local state of emergency
and the Alberta Energy System operator
issued a grid alert as demand hid an
all-time high when we get into what's
called a grid alert situation where all
available supply has been used and we
now need to use backup that's when we
get into a grid alert and that's when we
call upon these reserves that we keep
for situations like
this a 27-year-old man died after his
Jeep slid into an oncoming snow plow in
Calgary Friday
night for ranchers animal safety has
also been a concern big thing is to make
sure the cattle are fed and cared for
and and okay this unusual polar vortex
is causing a deep freeze in the prairies
as well and it continues to force delays
and cancellations at airports across
western Canada Katherine art Global News
Vancouver and now we go further west
Global News meteorologist Peter quinland
joins me from Saskatoon Peter some
staggering numbers out there what's it
like where you
are for here in sasun temperatures have
been below -30 windshields from -40 to -
53 since Thursday and are not expected
to warm up until early next week to the
Southwest in Swift Current it felt
likeus 59 with the windshield this
morning and windshields have been in
those minus 50s for over 24 hours
windshields approaching the minus 60s in
Alberta this week with dozens of low
temperature records broken and extreme
cold warnings for all of Alberta
Saskatchewan much of Manitoba NBC to the
east though we've had this winter storm
bringing in heavy snow to parts of
Southern Ontario and Quebec uh the
Griffith area in Ontario has reported 30
to 40 cm St colan in uh Southern Quebec
31.8 cm and the Ottawa Valley 15 to 27
CM but the Arctic air with the polar
vortex that usually sits over the North
Pole that was over western Canada is
Shifting East causing temperatures to
plunge to Southern Ontario Quebec and
the maritimes but that's going to allow
some relief through western Canada where
windshields will finally clamber their
way out of Theus 50s into Theus 30s on
the prairies and along the west coast
where they couldn't open ski resorts due
to a lack of snow and warmth in December
and then had to shut them down due to
this cold snap we'll finally see some
relief as we head into next weekend
could even see positive temperatures on
the way but meantime on the Prairies
Farah I have this bad tendency to leave
my swim bag in the car and look what
happened my swim shorts and my uh gym
shirt are completely frozen solid
they're like cardboard so the Arctic air
impacting all aspects of life here on
the Prairies far might have to dip that
in the hot tub Peter quinland thanks for
your forecast for us tonight from
Saskatoon South of the Border Fierce
winter weather continues to Pummel parts
of the US in Iowa frigid conditions
canceled more events in the Republican
presidential candidates race ahead of
Monday's caucuses but it's done little
to stop candidates from campaigning in
Western New York a dangerous winter
storm has triggered a state of emergency
to prepare for heavy snow and high winds
this weekend and that has affected the
NFL playoffs as well with a Sunday game
between Buffalo and Pittsburgh postponed
to Monday but in Missouri minus 20°
temperatures are not stopping Kansas
City from playing against Miami
tonight to Taiwan next where millions of
Voters have rebuffed China and elected a
presidential candidate from the
incumbent Democratic people's party for
an unprecedented third term in
office thousands gathered to celebrate
the dpp's win today which will extend
its 8-year term in the presidential
office William lie the party's vice
president since 2020 will be taking over
the top job and will look to lead the
island through a testy relationship with
Beijing David Aken
reports an adoring crowd cheers for its
new president elect William L leader of
taiwan's democratic people's party or
DPP won Saturday's election with more
than 40% of the vote in the campaign
where the central issue was taiwan's
relationship with mainland China I think
that this is the first
time uh since 1996 that I would say that
China was the number one issue the
people have given uh the the current
ruling party DPP an unprecedented third
year uh third term
so that's great uh so that means uh the
the foreign policy is working Li is the
64-year-old son of a coal miner he was a
physician specializing in spinal cord
injuries before going into
Politics the secret to his political
success a promise to stick to the status
quo of walking that tight rope of
avoiding anything that would provoke
mainland China while maintaining
taiwan's independence of action and its
defense of its own democracy we had to
win because
we have to protect democracy indeed
that's what moved this
voter I cast my vote for taiwan's
Independence she says for us to freely
enjoy our democracy and so it's the idea
of continuing on on a good path and
people were repeating that that slogan
and I think it I think it was uh
convincing I think dones people sent to
the message to the Beijing is that uh we
want peace uh we there there are many
ways to go about it but But ultimately
nobody wants War Beijing did not want
Lie To Win It has called him a
separatist and a troublemaker and after
lie one beijing's Taiwan Affairs office
issued a statement saying it hoped the
majority of what it called Taiwan
compatriots would recognize the quote
extreme harm of the dpp's Taiwan
Independence line lie for his part said
he is determined to safeguard Taiwan
from threats and intimidation from China
but he is also willing to engage in
talks with the communist government of
China on the basis of what he called
dignity and parity David aen Global News
Ottawa the United States has carried out
another air strike on a houthi
controlled site in Yemen overnight us
officials confirmed its forces targeted
a location which it considers to pose a
threat to commercial vessels in the Red
Sea the strike comes just one day after
British and US forces targeted nearly 30
houi positions in Yemen while conducting
Fresh Military drills today the Iran
backed Rebel group threatened what it
called a strong and effective response
to the
attacks President Joe Biden meantime
said he delivered a private message to
Iran today about the houthi attacks
although he declined to go into further
detail these strikes which were
supported by Canada have diminished hope
for many of negotiating peace in the
region as the Israel Hamas War also
rages on our Eric senson spoke to one
former top Us official on the peace
effort and what these strikes could mean
Eric far the conflict in the Middle East
escalated dangerously this week as a
us-led coalition became combatants
attacking houie Targets in Yemen one
former State Department official
believes that confrontation can be
contained I don't see that as being a
front that that has a lot of potential
to to explode Frank Lowenstein a former
Envoy on Israeli Palestinian
negotiations says the houis are unlikely
to muster a strong military response
after the bombings by the US and UK
aircraft but he told us on this week's
the West block that the fighting in Gaza
will go on for at least three or four
more months as the Israelis try to
eliminate Hamas they've killed maybe a
third to a half of the Hamas Fighters
and so the Israelis have no intention of
backing down I don't think this talk of
a day after is is really accurate still
a day after will eventually come and
Lowenstein hopes that after all the
Carnage a two-state solution that
includes an independent Palestinian
State could eventually be achieved maybe
the Israelis will take a step back when
they get done with this campaign and ask
themselves is this a sustainable way for
us to live and hopefully they'll see the
light and say okay we have to do some
things differently here in order to get
Saudi normalization in order to get
support for reconstruction but that is a
long way off first the war has to end
and the Israeli government probably has
to change Lowenstein says a two-state
solution will not happen as long as
Benjamin Netanyahu is still in power
Eric senson in Ottawa thank you Eric and
you can watch Eric's full interview
tomorrow on the west block right here on
global right now that campaign you just
heard Frank Lowenstein reference shows
no signs of slowing down with dozens
reportedly killed in overnight strikes
in
[Applause]
Gaza the Gaza Health Ministry says 135
Palestinians were killed in the last 24
hours including at least 13 members of
the same family after a strike leveled
house in the southern city of Raa
Israeli Defense Forces say they have
approved a new plan for troops in their
southern command to keep pressing in
what they call the enemy's territory
with the war entering its 100th day
tomorrow the IDF Chief emphasized his
troops efforts have shifted from the
north and are now concentrated to the
center and south of the Gaza
Strip in Columbia more than 30 people
were killed after a Mudslide swept onto
a busy highway on Friday
this video captures the terrifying
moment when part of the mountain gave
way submerging multiple cars and people
who tried to run away more than 30
others were also injured and an unknown
number of people are still
missing the clock is ticking to repay
money meant to help during covid coming
up how struggling small businesses are
scrambling ahead of next week's siba
loan
deadline
[Music]
the deadline is now less than a week
away for hundreds of thousands of small
businesses to repay a Federal Loan the
Canadian emergency business account or
siba offered businesses tens of
thousands of dollars to help with the
impact of covid shutdowns but as they
payback deadline looms thousands are now
turning to the world of independent
online lenders for last minute help
Abigail Bean reports we make them and
offer them as rentals to the film
industry the Vancouver Art Department
makes props for film and TV owner Grant
Harrison says they were hit twice first
by covid and then by writer and actor
strikes one day we had like 30
television shows that we are supplying
uh products to and the next day we had
zero he took the maximum $60,000 Sia
loan a Lifeline but he has to repay it
by January 18th to keep the 20,000
forgivable portion something that just
wasn't possible until don't get stuck at
the back of the line and miss out apply
with Merchant growth Harrison saw an ad
like this from Merchant growth one of
the independent lenders offering to
refinance siba loans at first he was
skeptical but his bank was taking weeks
to get him an appointment he got the
merchant money in a couple of days it
actually blew our minds and the people
got back to us right away and you know
didn't ask us
to didn't ask for my first born and did
ask for a mortgage founder David Jen
says they get siba inquiries from more
than a thousand businesses every day I
think it's helpful for people to know
that there's a non-bank lending industry
out there that uses technology makes it
really convenient saves you time and and
says yes a lot more often that doesn't
mean they're bad it just means that
they're different non-bank lenders
generally charge higher interest rates
for merchant grow that ranges from the
low teens to low 20s alternatively a
business will be charged a much much
lower 5% by the government with 3 years
to pay but by not meeting the deadline
they lose up to
$220,000 which could make the highin
loan cheaper and an interesting business
venture says this marketing Professor
there's the snake oil salesman and
there's the old idea of PT Barnum and
that people are getting
swindled I think the key thing to
remember here is that we have a lot of
regulations in our financial sector that
for the most most part prevent that sort
of thing going on while the big five
banks dominate more non-traditional
online lenders are popping up experts
say due to improved technology and
savings without bricks and mortar those
low costs of Entry are going to have
somebody come along with say the killer
app or the killer way that uh especially
with young people they're going to say
hey I'm not committed to the big six the
way that gen xers and older Baby Boomers
might be connected to the idea of
traditional banking every everyone
agrees it's important to do your
homework to figure out the option that's
best for each business and a lesser
known but key part of the fine print
businesses can get an extension until
March 28th to repay their loan and keep
the forgivable portion but only if they
apply to their original bank before
January 18th a business can also apply
to a third-party lender as long as
they've applied with their original Bank
too Abigail bman Global News
Ottawa
Ahad blackface backlash why Montreal
Puppeteer is suing an anti-racism group
over his own
[Music]
creation a Quebec artist is launching a
lawsuit against a member of an
anti-racism group accusing them of
damaging his reputation that issue a
puppet that Frank sylvest uses for one
of his performances that some have
criticized as a depiction of blackface
as Mike Armstrong explains the artist AR
argues that his controversial prop is
simply a caricature of
himself the show is called the
incredible secret of
Blackbeard in it artist Frank sylvest
portrays a series of characters and at
one point interacts with a puppet that
was a problem for
some sylvest says the people who
criticized him never saw the show and
knew nothing about it well the show was
supposed to be a part of Black History
Month last year and performed for
children as sylvest has been doing since
2009 if I showed that to a four-year-old
it's scary but in February of last year
several groups from the black community
spoke out calling the puppet blackface
and offensive Al Babino the spokesperson
for an anti-racism group the red
Coalition took to Twitter he said
sylvest was an example of a black
cellout who didn't want to upset his
Masters sylvest says in the Fallout of
that criticism some of his performances
were cancelled and he lost potential
bookings sylvest sent a lawyer's letter
to Babino last fall demanding an apology
that never came this week he filed a
lawsuit for just over $26,000 in Damages
he claims the criticism was a violation
of his freedom of expression and
defamation to call someone racist when
it's unreasonable to do so when you have
no good reason to do so that's
defamation Babino and the red Coalition
are calling the law frivolous in a
statement they say critics were
expressing their disapproval and that
the puppet plays on historic stereotypes
depicting black people as grotesque
dimwitted lazy buffoonish cowardly
superstitious and overly
cheerful sures says it's just supposed
to be an exaggerated version of himself
he says he's been using the puppet for
more than 20 years what's changed he
says is the climate where instead of
listening to artists people try to
cancel them GS from Global News
Montreal next unintended result why
Banning the practice of shark Finning
might be pushing the ocean Predators
closer to
[Music]
Extinction sharks have long been
perceived as the apex predator of the
Seas yet despite their reputation a new
study found that human activity is still
the biggest threat to these animals and
it's also a Frank assessment over
whether efforts to protect them like
Banning shark Finning have worked at all
Heidi pachik
explains always fascinating often feared
sharks are powerful ocean Predators but
new research finds fishing by another
Predator us is killing more of them
despite a 10-fold increase of
regulations that are supposed to protect
sharks from over fishing um we do not
see a global decline in the mortality of
sharks the study in the journal science
determined shark mortality from fishing
increased in a 7-year period reaching
101 million killed in 2019 more than 30%
of those sharks threaten species many
caught unintentionally Even in our own
Waters sharks still get caught as by
catch in a lot of our directed fisheries
and we should have figured out how to
address shark bycatch um in our
Fisheries in this country since the
1990s many jurisdictions have prohibited
shark Finning hacking off the fins and
disc guarding the carcass some including
Canada later required any shark landed
to have fins attached and then almost 5
years ago Canada became the first G20
country to ban fin Imports but
researchers found in the end demand for
shark only increased Harvesters finding
new markets for the whole fish so what
was well intentioned and the right thing
to do had this unintended consequence of
making the shark trade more valuable
shark oil found in cosmetics cartilage
in supplements in many countries people
rely on shark meat because it's
affordable changing the cultural aspect
of especially like uh Coastal
communities that have been eating this
for so long uh it's also really hard so
while Banning shark Finning was a start
what reduces overall mortality is catch
restrictions protected areas and phasing
out particularly indiscriminate fishing
gears like Gil Nets better ways he says
to save shark species facing Extinction
Heidi pic Global News
Halifax and that's global national for
this Saturday night I'm far ner on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's here
Canada is this snowy owl chilling near
Calgary until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good
night
[Music]